le choix de l'école correspond donc
parfois des convictions profondes
cependant l'adoption d'un établissement
par les parents n'est pas forcément
idéologique dans de nombreuses familles
les enfants ne fréquentent pas le même
type d'école ils viennent hervier si
eric mangini ont rencontré une famille
partagée entre le public et le privé
16 heures comme tous les jours elisabeth
de fresnes
à quand sa fille à la sortie du
sacré-coeur un collège privé de
versailles
juste le temps de récupérer emilie 11
ans et la voilà qui font chercher
valérie huit ans la petite dernière
scolarisés à ligue les rios l'école
primaire de buc laïque et publics pour
les de fresnes public privé la question
est avant tout d'ordre pratique
les deux aînés ont commencé à l'école de
la république avant de poursuivre dans
des institutions religieuses
motif un fléchissement dans leurs
résultats scolaires ce qui a motivé je
pense que on considère que les enfants
sont bien tenues sont sont bien encadrés
s'il ya quelque chose qui va pas on sait
tout de suite on n'attend pas six mois
pour nous le dira
nicolas est un garçon
quittez pas qu'il peut plus être qu'un
autre mais qui a en effet avec quelques
petits problèmes et c'était la suite du
conseil d'ailleurs d'une institutrice du
public que j'ai foi que nous avons mis
nicolas dans le privé et d'ailleurs on a
tout de suite senti que ça allait mieux
pour les deux fresnes il n'est pas
question de philosophie enfants ils ont
pratiqué eux-mêmes les deux sites
fiables par tendance on a toujours le
désir de faire faire à ses enfants ce
que l'on a fait soi même ou au mieux de
ce que l'on a fait soi même mais je ne
pense pas que d'à priori non non puisque
la troisième sans doute verra peut-être
au collège public d'autant plus que
c'est en face de chez nous c'est quand
même beaucoup plus pratique publique ou
privée valérie encore le temps de voir
venir
à moins qu'elle ne rentre au
conservatoire de musique
il est